mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
triangle abc has side lengths of 3
4 and 5. a square is inscribed with
one side along the side ac
what is the area of the inscribed square
i think papa from india for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
since triangle abc has side lengths of 3
4 and 5 it is a right triangle
the longer leg is four thirds the
shorter leg
and the shorter leg is three-fourths the
longer leg
this inscribed square divides the entire
right triangle
into a series of similar triangles
this will be similar to the entire
triangle we also have
that this triangle will be similar to
the entire triangle
and we have this triangle will be
similar to the triangle abc
suppose the square has a side length
equal to s
in this triangle we have its shorter leg
is equal to s
which means its longer leg will be equal
to 4 over
3 times s in this triangle
the longer leg is equal to s which means
the shorter leg
will be 3 4 multiplied by s
we now have the sum of these distances
will be equal to the length of the
hypotenuse
we can then solve this equation for s
and we get that
s is equal to 60 over 37
to get the area of the square we will
square
the value of s and we get 3600
over 1369 which is approximately equal
to 2.63
and that's our answer what a delightful
problem
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels
on youtube see you next episode as we
continue to solve the world's problems
one video at a time
[Music]
you